I want to take a little bit of time to talk
about the reality of whether gun safety regulations
work to reduce not just gun violence but violence
more generally because the right has a lot
of really concise and neat sounding talking
points. I've said before, the right has the
advantage on framing George Lakoff has written
about this. Uh, abortion is murder, so it
should be illegal. That is a really simple
talking point. And the left position on abortion
is not the opposite of that. It is nuance
that is complex and on guns, the right has
guns don't kill people. People kill people.
More guns would make a safer a gun. Free zones
are the problem because only good guys follow
the rules and the bad guys will bring guns
into gun free zones, more guns, less crime.
People will find a way to do the killing even
without a gun.
So banning guns are making them harder to
access, doesn't do anything. Now there are
actually a whole host of ways to think about
this and all of them point in one direction,
which is actually gun safety rules and restrictions
do work. There was a really good post on our
subreddit by a user named not stylistic say
on, and some of their ideas are in this segment.
Now, one argument that's common is it doesn't
matter what you make illegal people will get
it if it's a good way to kill people. Has
anybody heard of a mass killing via grenade?
Grenades are easy to detonate. They have a
big blast radius. You don't have to be nearly
as accurate as you do with a firearm yet there
are no mass killing incidents involving grenades.
Well, why not? It turns out there's really
strict regulation of grenades. They're really
difficult to get.
Another example, m four and ar 15 rifles are
very similar. Different barrel sizes. The
[inaudible] has a a some firing modes, three
round burst and fully auto firing options,
but all else being equal, m fours are harder
to get. They're more expensive. The mass shootings
are overwhelmingly Ar, fifteens and never
m fours. Wow. What a shocker. What about just
in general, fully automatic weapons, fully
automatic weapons would do a ton of killing
in a mass shooting, but they aren't used because
you need to jump through all sorts of legal
hoops to get them. They're really expensive.
So the laws do work. The guns that are more
difficult to get and more expensive aren't
used in mass shootings. So then some people
will bring up, well the real problem is handguns
and individual homicides, not mass shootings
and the types of firearms used within them.
It's really a distraction.
You can kill one person in many, many different
ways. And it is difficult to stop a determined
person from killing one other person. But
the success of mass shootings or mass killing
events is much more dictated by the firepower
and the destructive nature of that fire power
that's available. And if you zoom out and
you look at studies across many countries,
the theme, the arc is homicide rate goes down
when gun restrictions are made law. But it's
gotta be taken seriously. It can't be just
one law. There's a study published by Oxford
University press. What do we know about the
association between firearm legislation and
firearm related injuries? What we learn is
that it usually takes a pretty major legislative
overhaul. It's not just background checks
alone to see significant changes, restricting
access to guns and their purchase is associated
with a reduction in firearm deaths.
This tells us that just passing background
checks is likely to have only a very small
effect. What we need is a combination of 100%
universal background checks. Yes, restrictions
on the most deadly weapons requiring permitting
and licensing for guns. I'd like to see mandatory
insurance policies for gun owners as well
and Elizabeth Warren is proposing a lot of
this stuff and I'll get to that a little bit
later. When you look at countries like South
Africa and Australia, even when you look within
states in the United States that have made
changes, the results are very clear, but in
the end, none of this matters because on this
issue the facts don't matter. They are well
funded. On the pro gun side. They're well-equipped
to dismiss any study and to tell you that
you're a bad person for wanting this stuff
and you're against freedom. And in the end,
in addition to these changes legislatively,
there has to be a cultural change.
I've been talking about this for years. At
this point, we need to stop being a culture
where so many people want so many guns. We
need to stop being a culture where so many
people see guns as a tool to solve problems,
be the societal, political, cultural, personal.
We need to stop being a culture that raises
so many radicals and extremists, but we also
need to do all of these other things which
any other civilized country would have done
if they were in our position, which countries
like New Zealand so quickly did once they
suffered a mass killing event like this. So
the policies work, but they don't work individually.
They need to be a package of policies. But
the culture is a big part of this and so many
other things relate to this. None of which,
none of which the pro gun fetishist American
right wing connected to the very well funded
a gun lobby is willing to even consider. Let
me know what you think. I'm on Twitter at
d pacman. I hope you'll follow me there. I
hope you'll follow the show on Twitter at
David Pakman show
and I hope you'll join me this evening. 6:30
PM eastern time for a live stream on twitch
at twitch.tv/david
Pakman